und willkommen zu unserem nächsten fall
so domenico lo russo der das muss ich so
sagen für mich ein echter held ist denn
der war damals mit seiner freundin an
der isar unterwegs und seine freundin
die ist angespuckt worden und domenico
der hat nicht weggeguckt sondern er hat
seine freundin verteidigt und den mann
der da gespuckt hat zur rede gestellt
und dieser mann der zieht dann plötzlich
ein messer und sticht es domenico ins
herz und tötet ihn damit
domenico lo russo ist jung und hat große
pläne denn er will heiraten
2012 zieht der italiener mit seiner
verlobten in münchen zusammen sie
arbeitet als dolmetscherin er als
ingenieur
gemeinsam wollen die italiener in bayern
leben und eine familie gründen sie sind
glücklich in münchen ihrer traumstadt
bis der abend des 28
mai 2013 ihr glück zerstört domenico lo
russo muss sterben weil er nicht
hinnehmen möchte dass jemand seine große
liebe einfach so an spuckt mitten in der
münchner innenstadt direkt an der isar
wird domenico erstochen und sein mörder
ist bis heute nicht gefasst
wer sticht scheinbar grundlos auf einen
jungen mann ein nimmt ging sein leben
und eine gemeinsame zukunft mit seiner
verlobten
[Musik]
exklusiv treffen wir dominikus
geschwister erstmals sprechen sie mit
deutschen journalisten über die tat
es ist nicht so dass denn der fall
gelöst wird dies der familie wirklich
frieden geben würde
das ist etwas anderes etwas persönliches
aber es ist richtig
dass sich der juristische fall schließt
wenn der mörder festgenommen wird
lakata belassen
weil domenico einen unbekannten zur rede
stellt der seine verlobte bespuckt hat
wird der 31-jährige zum opfer einer
tödlichen messerattacke
und als bildreporter begleite ich diesen
fall natürlich bis ins kleinste detail
luft
[Musik]
in der hoffnung dass es irgendwann
hinweise gibt die zur ergreifung des
täters wird wird die familie jemals
erfahren wer ihn umgebracht hat
mord verjährt nie und wir gehen ja von
mord ermittlungen aus
[Musik]
und deswegen sind wir natürlich
weiterhin auf der suche nach dem täter
der fall domenico lo russo und die suche
nach dessen mörder beschäftigt auch bild
reporter karl heim seit jahren immer
noch ist kein täter gefasst der mord an
der isar wird zum cold case seit der
messerattacke berichtet bild regelmäßig
über neueste entwicklungen in diesem
fall
15.000 personen überprüft aber immer
noch kein täter neuer zeuge sah
dominikus todeskampf
neuer dna test isa killer hat braune
haare und braune augen
ein mord mitten in münchen wir gehen an
den ort des verbrechens an eine der
beliebtesten radstrecken der stadt
direkt an der isar
und jedes mal wenn es in münchen eine
neue messe tag gegeben bei der es für
die ermittler kein erkennbares motiv
gibt fragen sich ermittler und
journalisten war es der isa mörder noch
immer bleibt der fall ein rätsel bei der
staatsanwaltschaft münchen lagern über
200 ordner zum fall domenico lo russo
bild reporter karl km ii trifft
oberstaatsanwältin anne leiding bis
heute ermittelt sie in diesem fall wir
können bisher keine verbindung zwischen
täter und opfer herstellen weil wir
natürlich auch die verlobte gefragt
haben und da haben sich einfach keine
hinweise dazu ergeben dass es da
irgendeinen zusammenhang gegeben haben
könnte der fall wirft immer noch viele
fragen auf
süditalien in der stadt potenza leben
dominikus geschwister auch seine
verlobte ist wieder dort möchte aber
nicht über den mord sprechen wie tina
und paulo logos so wollen endlich wissen
wer ihren bruder getötet hat mit ihrer
hilfe rekonstruieren wir den bislang
ungeklärten fall
hier am wiener platz im münchner
stadtteil haidhausen lebt domenico
gemeinsam mit seiner verlobten
zusammen wollen sie eine familie gründen
die beiden waren erst kürzlich aus der
südlichen stadt potenza hierher gezogen
um sich ein neues leben aufzubauen
jetzt wollten sie ihrer familie von der
verlobung erzählen doch dazu kam es
nicht mehr es ist der 28
mai 2013 ein lauer frühlingstag
domenico kommt gerade von einem
deutschkurs und trifft sich mit seiner
freundin am gärtnerplatz zusammen fahren
sie auf dem isarradweg entlang eine der
bekanntesten und beliebtesten
radstrecken mitten im zentrum münchens
sie wollen zusammen nach hause
[Musik]
gegen 22 uhr auf höhe der
corneliusbrücke gegenüber vom
europäischen patentamt bespuckt ein
bisher unbekannter mann dominikus 28
jährige verlobte
domenico hat die attacke wohl nicht
mitbekommen erst als ihn seine freundin
eingeholt hat und davon erzählt hat hat
er sich auf sein rad gesetzt ist
umgedreht und wollte den täter zur rede
stellen doch was domenico nicht ahnte
der mann hatte ein messer dabei nein
nein wir konnten uns so etwas nicht
vorstellen
wie es dort war er hat uns immer
vermittelt dass er sich in münchen steht
sicher gefühlt hat
von domenico ein klärendes gespräch mit
dem unbekannten sucht sieht dieser ein
messer und sticht zu der italiener
kämpft um sein leben
dominikus verlobt gericht sofort einen
krankenwagen
was genau passiert ist weiß sie nicht
sie hat das zunächst nicht verstanden
erst später hat sie realisiert dass da
blut auf dem boden ist
aber die schwere der verletzung und dass
es ein angriff gegeben hat das war ihr
noch nicht bewusst
aber als sie das blut gesehen hat und
mein bruder bewusstlos geworden ist da
ist ihr klar geworden dass etwas ganz
schlimmes passiert sein muss aber was
genau passiert ist das hat sie nicht
gesehen
der täter ein mann um die 30 mit
längerer jacke oder mantel und
umhängetasche so beschreibt im dominikus
verlobte
der unbekannte flieht nach der attacke
wahrscheinlich über die corneliusbrücke
45 minuten nach dem angriff durch den
messerstecher stirbt domenico im
krankenhaus
der ingenieur wird nur 31 jahre alt
erstochen nur weil er nicht hinnehmen
wollte dass jemand seine verlobte an
spuckt
wir können natürlich mit den täter so
lange wie eben nicht kennen auch nur
mutmaßen wir wissen nicht was das für
eine person ist und was die motivation
dieser tat war wir können nur sagen dass
eben die art der ausführung
für uns grund ist hier mordmerkmale
anzunehmen nämlich die heimtücke und die
niedrigen beweggründe weil wir eben
sagen also jemanden da einfach wegen so
eines nichtigen anlasses ist so zu
überfallen und zu töten ist eben
heimtücke und auch niedriger beweggrund
und für uns eben daher mord die polizei
gründete die soko cornelius am tatort
wird dna des täters sichergestellt in
dominikus vun de findet sich fremdes
blut der täter hat sich verletzt das
natürlich unser wichtigster
ermittlungsansatz nur sie brauchen für
die identifizierung des täters immer
einen dna-abgleich das heißt wir haben
jetzt diese dna wir haben die natürlich
auch untersucht und jetzt brauchen wir
aber natürlich irgendwo noch einen
aufscheinen des täters in einer anderen
in einem anderen registern irgendwann
andere straftaten begeht dann kommt er
vielleicht mal ins register und dann
können wir abgleichen
doch in den internationalen datenbanken
gibt es bislang keinen treffer
bis ende mai 2013 überprüft die polizei
15.000 personen und nimmt von 6500
männern speichelproben handybenutzer die
in der nähe waren anwohner passanten
auch die gäste eines konzertes in der
muffathalle werden überprüft nur elf
gehminuten vom tatort entfernt spielt
hier die schwedische punk band dead bei
apple
oft ist die kleidung in dieser szene
ausgefallen und der täter soll am
tatabend einen langen mantel getragen
haben doch auch hier fehlt der
entscheidende treffer die ermittler
wissen dass sich der täter bei dem
angriff selbst verletzt haben muss mit
einem aufruf in einem ärzteblatt suchen
sie darum den mörder einen treffer gibt
es wieder nicht am 30 november wird die
soko cornelius aufgelöst aber es wird
weiter ermittelt
2020 wird ein neues dna gutachten
vorgestellt
[Musik]
obwohl die so cornelius vor rund drei
jahren aufgelöst wurde habe man sich vor
anderthalb jahren ermittler noch mal neu
mit diesem fall beschäftigt und haben
eine spezielle dna analyse in innsbruck
bei der universität innsbruck in auftrag
gegeben und hofften so dass sie mehr
durch diese dna analyse herausfinden
können wer dieser täter ist und wie alt
er sein könnte leider hat das dna
material nicht ausgereicht dass man das
alter genau bestimmen konnte aber man
konnte herausfinden dass er zu einer
großen wahrscheinlichkeit braune haare
und braune augen haben müsste doch auch
diese analyse bringt die ermittler nicht
weiter der fall dominique bleibt ein
cold case
aber eine anonyme nachricht an die
geschwister dominikus könnte jetzt den
durchbruch bringen mit uns sprechen
seine schwester und sein bruder erstmals
über das verbrechen und die neuen
hinweise zum mörder ihres bruders gleich
in achtung fahndung
[Musik]
vor acht jahren wird domenico lo russo
brutal ermordet mitten in der münchner
innenstadt
er wollte einen mann zur rede stellen
der seine verlobte angespuckt hatte dann
ersticht ihn der unbekannte mit 31
jahren stirbt der italiener bis heute
gibt es keine spur zum mörder
eine anonyme nachricht an dominikus
geschwister könnte jetzt neue hinweise
liefern bild reporter karl keim trifft
exklusiv dominikus schwester wie tina
und seinen bruder paolo lohro so was hat
es mit dem hinweis auf sich steht der
fall vor der aufklärung
[Musik]
per mail mit einer anonyme mail adresse
geo die dato wir haben das dem anwalt
sofort weitergegeben
märz in der mail hieß es wir sollten
nach einem ex mitglied einer metalband
suchen
[Musik]
an diesem tag hatten diese person zwar
nicht gespielt aber
dieser anonyme hinweisgeber sagt dass
diese person trotzdem beim konzert war
da sind halt seine großteil des
vorhabens der presse ein dach contest es
soll sich um einen kampfsportler handeln
und derjenige soll sehr wütend gewesen
sein
weil er aus der band geschmissen wurde
diese information hat jetzt auch die
polizei
also machen acht jahren solche genauen
angaben so detailliert
das ist für mich schon sehr überraschen
paulo und wie tina wollen endlich wissen
wer hat domenico getötet seine verlobte
gibt keine interviews aber sie träumt
von domenico sagt für sie sei er nur
körperlich tot
im namen meiner ganzen familie
wer informationen hat oder diese person
kennt oder aus dem umfeld dieser person
kommt nie was der waren mit
melden sie sich umgehend bei der polizei
auch acht jahre nach der tat ist jeder
hinweis
jede information wichtig um den fall
endlich aufzuklären
[Musik]
dem anonymen hinweis auf den möglichen
mörder von domenico gehen nun zwei
ermittler nach mehr sagt die
staatsanwaltschaft aus
ermittlungstaktischen gründen nicht dazu
darüber hinaus will sie folgendes wissen
es geht damals um den vertrag 28 fünfter
2013 in der erhard straße nahe der
corneliusbrücke wer dort irgendetwas
festgestellt hat und sei es nur ein ganz
kleiner hinweis ist bisher für nicht
wichtig gehalten hat der kann sich gerne
jederzeit bei der polizei melden
gesucht werden hinweise zu einer
männlichen person um die dreißig mit
braunen haaren und braunen augen die
eine lange jacke oder mantel und eine
umhängetasche getragen hat und
schnittverletzungen an den armen oder
händen hat jeder hinweis kann die
entscheidende spur im fall domenico lo
russo sein wem ist am 28
mai 2013 in münchen im raum erhard
straße corneliusbrücke am isarradweg
etwas aufgefallen
sachdienliche hinweise bitte an die
polizeidirektion münchen oder jede
andere polizeidienststelle
acht jahre nach dem mord an domenico
wollen seine geschwister den täter
endlich fassen
[Musik]
wir wollen einen schlusspunkt geworden
und die akte schließen ich und meine
familie müssen das ganze zumindest
juristisch beenden aber meine gefühle
sind ganz anders
wer hat ihren bruder brutal ermordet
jeder hinweis kann zur aufklärung am
mord an domenico lo russo beitragen um
den bisher ungeklärten mord an der isar
endlich zu lösen
und wir wollen der familie von domenico
helfen endlich gewissheit zu bekommen
wer hat den jungen mann ermordet können
sie sich vielleicht erinnern kommen sie
aus münchen waren sie 2013 dort und
haben etwas mitbekommen können sie sich
vielleicht doch noch an etwas erinnern
haben sie beobachtungen gemacht helfen
sie den isa mord aufzuklären
hinweise nimmt die polizei münchen unter
der nummer 089 2910 0 entgegen